عرب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان في حديث للجزيره عن
استعداد الجيش السوداني للتفاوض اذا
انسحبت قوه الدعم السريع خارج الخرطوم في
المقابل شدد قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان حميدتي في مقابله مع الجزيره على
ضروره التخلص من البرهان لاطلاق التحول
الديمقراطي مشيرا الى انه مع هدنه انسانيه
ووقت مؤقت لاطلاق النار
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء الاعزاء كان
ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه
مسارات كيف بدت امكانيه التفاوض والتوصل
الى وقف القتال بين طرفي القتال من خلال
اخر تصريحات الصادره عن البرهان
وما هي الاعتبارات والحسابات التي تحكم
الرجلين في ادارتهما للخلاف الدم الذي نشب
بين القوات التي تنقاد
لاوامرهما وهل في ذلك ما يفسح مجالا
لتسويه ما ممكنه
وكيف يتلقى المجتمع الدولي تطور مواقف
الرجلين وما هي الاوراق التي يمكن توظيفها
لدفعهما نحو منطق الحوار والتسويه بدل
المضي اكثر في القتال وسعي لتصفيه الطرف
المقابل
بين دخان المعارك وازيز الرصاص يتطلع
مراقبون الى ما بين ثنايا التصريحات التي
ادلى بها كل من البرهان واحنتي الى قناه
الجزيره وفيها تحدث عن مجريات القتال
واسبابه واحتمالات وقته وبالقدر الذي شدد
فيه الرجلان على المضي في مواجهه الاخر
حتى النهايه لم يخلو حديثهما من اشارات
الى امكانيه التفاوض وما يرتبط بذلك من
شروط واهداف على نحو لا يقفل الباب امام
بصيص حل لكنه لا يخفي التوصل الى ذلك
حاليا
رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان
اعرب عن استعداد القوات المسلحه للتفاوض
اذا انسحبت قوه الدعم السريع خارج الخرطوم
والتزمت بمواقعها وفقا لاتفاق ديسمبر
كانون الاول الماضي في المقابل قال قائد
قوات الدعم السريع في السودان محمد حميدتي
في مقابله مع الجزيره ان الهدف من
العمليات العسكريه في السودان هو التخلص
من قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان والبدء
في عمليه التحول الديمقراطي
وفيما يتعلق بفرص الحل اضاف احمدتي انه
دعا الى هدنه انسانيه والى وقت لاطلاق
النار لفتره معينه لكن الطرف الاخر لا
يريد ذلك
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من الخرطوم عبر
الهاتف الرشيد المعتصم الباحث في مركز
الخرطوم للحوار وايضا من الخرطوم معنا
حافظ كبير الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن
بوسطن ينضم الينا تيموث السفير الامريكي
السابق في السودان سابدا معك سيد الرشيد
المعتصم هل وجدت في ثنايا كلام البرهان ما
يفيد الاستعداد للتفاوض في هذه المرحله
وقناعه بعدم امكانيه الغاء
الدعم السريع التي يصفها البرهان بالقوات
المتمرده هل باتت لديه هذه القناعه اليوم
من غير الممكن انا في يعني فيما اعتقد
وفيما يعني ان يرب الجيش او يقبل بمفاوضات
مع يعني حتى اذا كانت هناك مفاوضات على اي
مستوى لن يكون هناك دعم سريع لن تكون هناك
موازيه للجيش السوداني هذا امر شيبسي
محسوم والسوداني والشعب السوداني لم يرضى
لانه هذا القضيه ازمه سياسيه وازمه نفسيه
وسببت خلل في شكل الدوله وهيكلها
واصبح يعني اصبحت تشكل عظمه عدم يقين لدى
السودانيين واصبحت الدوله السودانيه نفسها
عروضه للانقسام يعني لكن كلام لكن سيد
الرشيد كلام كلام رئيس مجلس سياده واضح
انه مستعد للتفاوض اذا انسحبت قوه الدعم
السريع الى المناطق او وفقا لاتفاق ديسمبر
الماضي بينما كان يعني قبل يوم ين او
ثلاثه ايام يقول انه لا تفاوض حتى انهاء
او التخلص من هذه القوات المتمرده كما
يصفها هل الان قدم نوع من التنازل في هذا
الكلام عبد الفتاح البرهان
في القضيه السياسيه وفي القضايا العسكريه
لكن الى اي مدى هو سيفوز الرجل هذا ام
رنا ماذا سيحدث لكن انا في ظني الجيش هذه
معركه الجيش التي كان كانت مؤجله لانه
الجيش كان في مخلوق وكان لا يقبل اصلا
بوجود قوات مسلحه خارج دائره القوات
المسلحه لا تعتبر بعمر الجيش ولا تعمل
تحتها دائره وجود قوات مسلحه يعني مستقله
معناها هناك هناك جيشين وانا هناك دولتين
خاصه اذا اذا يعني خاصه في وجود يعني في
في علاقات خارجيه
عسكري مجموعه عسكريه لديها علاقات خارجيه
وتتحرك وتتحدث في السياسه لم تجيبني
تحديدا يعني البرهان هنا ماذا يعني ماذا
يفعل هو تكتيك ام هو فعلا مستعد للتفاوض
المتمردين يسعى لتحسين صورته الخارجيه
لا يعني قضيه الخاص والرساله الخارجيه
ربما تكون مهمه في هذا الشان يعني اعتقد
ذلك لكن
في اي اتجاه لا يمكن الاحتفاظ بقوه اسمها
الدعم السريع في ظل بشكل مستقيل هذا امر
لا يمكن اصلا الجيش لن يقبل هذا الامر سيد
سيد حافظ
ماذا قرات في كلام البرهان وكلام احمدتي
ايضا الذي
رفع السقف اذا اذا صح التعبير رفع السقف
وقال ان الهدف هو التخلص من البرهان
سيد حافظ
انقطع التواصل مع المحلل السياسي من
الخرطوم حافظ كبير سنعود اليه بالتاكيد
لكن سانتقل الى واشنطن مع تومي في
كارنيه السفير الامريكيه السابق في
السودان سيد تيموثي ماذا قرات في تصريحات
البرهان وحميدتي بشان موضوع التفاوض يعني
حماتي طرح موضوع الهدنه لاكثر من يوم
البرهان طرح التفاوض لكن بشروط كيف فهمت
هذه المواقف الجديده
اعتقد اني اتفق الى حد كبير مع السيد
الرشيد
بان هذا معجره تكتيك يستخدمه انه وان اي
منهما في الوقت الحالي لغير مستعد للدخول
في مفاوضات جاده ولكن رغم ذلك انا ايضا
لاحظت ان الامين العام للامم المتحده
واخرون قد اقترحوا بشده الهدنه لثلاثه
ايام فتره العيد وهذا امر انا اعتقد
الجميع يجب ان يضع الضغط على برهان وعلى
حميدتي اللي يوافق عليه
يعني تعتبر بان الجانبين
يخوضان ما يمكن تسميته بمعركه العلاقات
العامه لتحسين الصوره لكن في على ارض
الواقع هما ليس مستعدين للتفاوض اقله في
هذه المرحله
اعتقد نعم في هذا الوقت الذات نعم هذا هو
الكلام صحيح تماما ايا منهما غير مستعد
للتفاوض وعودنا نؤكد على نقطه اخرى
اثارها السيد الرشيد المعتصم وهي ان
الدوله الحديثه لا يمكن ان يكون فيها
جيشان مستقران عن بعضهما الاخر هذا بكل
بساطه امر غير ممكن
طيب ساعود الى السيد الرشيد المعتصم في
هذا المجال طيب اذا كانت هذه هي القناعه
لدى البرهان بانه لا يمكن ان يتعايش جيشان
بشكل متوازن وبقيادتين مختلفتين ولهما
علاقات دوليه ايضا متعدده ومختلفه لكل
منهما طيب هل يراهن فعلا عبد الفتاح
البرهان على التخلص من نحماتي او من الدعم
السريع عسكريا وهل بالامكان ذلك
الجيش السوداني الان يعمل
مطلق وليس فيه
لا يمكن ان ليس فيه خلاف
السودانيين اطلاق الان يدعمون الجيش
السوداني ما عدا قله للاسياسيين مجموعه
الاطاري وبعض المجموعات وهؤلاء ليس الامر
بعمق شعبي كل المكونات الاهليه حتى في
دارفور التي يعني يجعل بعض
الاشخاص في الخارج والمحللين والدوائر
التي تحلل باعتبارات كده غير مكتمله
معلومات غير مكتمله البيئه التي يعني
ينتمي اليها حين الان المكونه الاهلي فيها
اصبح يعني ارادته التاريخيه مع الدوله
السودانيه علاقه تعطي ارتباط قوي وعلاقته
مع الجيش السوداني تاريخيا يعني منذ
الاستقرار وفي فتره الاستعمار الاولى
البريطاني يعني هؤلاء هم نفسهم الم
جموعات التي
فهذه البيئه هي بيئه دعم للارتباطها مع
الجيش السوداني ارتباط نفسي وارتباط
تاريخي قديم اسمح لي هنا انتقل الى سيد
حافظ كبير عاده معنا من الخرطوم سيد حافظ
كنت سالتك عن
عن قراءتك لما بين السطور لتصريحات
البرهان واحميتي بشان امكانيه التفاوض
هناك راي تحدث عنه السيد الرشيد ووافقه
ضيفنا من
بوستن بان هذا تكتيك وعلاقات عامه ومحاوله
تحسين الصوره في الخارج لا اكثر ولا اقل
ما رايك
تحيه طيبه لك ولضيوفك الكرام للمشاهدين
انا يعني اختلف معهما في ان المخاطبات
ستاتي قريبا وهذا مؤشر خطاب اليوم مؤشر
الى ان هناك يعني تنازلات كبيره فقدمتها
الاطراف وان الحل يكون في التفاوض بعد
قناعه
الصراع لن يقود الى تحقيق اهدافهما وان
هذا الامر قيل من قبله يعني نحن شاهدنا
خلال التاريخ القريب
عندما يعني
يقول بانه لن يتفاوض قال ذلك مرتين مره في
مثل هذا اليوم من العمل 2017 بعد اعتصام
وكذلك مره اخرى بعد انقلاب خمس اكتوبر لكن
الجميع يعودون مره اخرى الى التفاوض هذا
هو الفريق
الحل مجموعات بالطبع تستثمر في هذا المناخ
لا تريد اي حوار وتريد اقص
اء من الدعم السريع تماما وبالتالي تريد
العمليه السياسيه
عفوا السيد السيد حافظ قلت ان
التفاوض بات قريبا بعدما قدمت الاطراف
تنازلات هل لك ان تخبرنا ما هي التنازلات
توضح لنا من الذي قدم تنازل
يعني نحن في اول يوم كان البرهان يصف قوات
الدعم السريع بانها المتمرده وانها غير
قانونيه وغير شرعيه اليوم تحدث اتكلم عنها
حديثا واختلف فقط مع قائدها وقال انه يقبل
التفاوض مع هي منظومه
او منظومه عسكريه وانه يقبل التفاوض مع
مستشاريها ولكنه لا يقبل التفاوض مع
قائدها كذلك قال بانه ابتداء لم يرفض
وانما هو طالب يعني هدنه انسانيه وان
الطرف الاخر هذه كلها تنازلات وهذا يعني
انهما في الايام المقبله يعني من خلال
الادوار التي تلعبها يعني الدبلوماسيه
وكذلك الاطراف المختلفه
هدنتين خلال المرحله الماضيه
لكن ربما في البدايه بصوره غريبه الذي
يهدد التفاوض ليس الواقع
الواقع على الارض وانما يهدد التفاوض
مجموعات ترى بضروره الحسم العسكري بهذه
المجموعات متشجره تجاه
من هي هذه المجموعات من هي هذه المجموعات
هذا الامر معروف عندنا في السودان لان
الجيش به مجموعات كبيره من النظام الفائت
هذه المجموعات تختلف ايدولوجيا مع مجموعه
الحريه والتغيير وبالتالي هي لا تريد
العوده
للتفاوض معها ولا تريد اشراكها مره اخرى
في السلطه الا وفق الصيغه معينه هذه
الصيغه يعني تدخل فيها جميع السودانيين
هذا المؤتمر الوطني وهذه ترفضها يعني قوه
الثوره
اريد ان اقول بان هذا الامر
اشد اتجاه الدعم السريع
العمليه سياسيه كانت في السابق موجود
ومنصوص عليه
خلاف وكذلك لم يوصل يعني تحركه في الفحل
السياسيه وفي اتفاق
حافظ نعم عفوا اسمح لي اعود الى الى ضيفنا
من بوستن تيمو في كارني بما ان الفكره
اتضحت بشكل كبير معنى ذكرته سيد حافظ سيد
تيموفي يعني بغض النظر عن كيف تنظر الى
تصريحات البرهان ان كانت تكتيك اعلامي
تحسين صوره
علاقات عامه لكن الا يمكن البناء عليها
والاستثمار بها من اجل الدفع نحو التفاوض
خصوصا ان ضيفنا حافظ قدير قبل قليل شرح
يعني
تدرج التنازل الذي قدمه البرهان ووصل الى
هذا الحد
نعم نعم هذا فعلا ما يمكن ان يعتقد به
ويظنه السيد حافظ لكن علينا ان ننظر الى
الخلافات الاساسيه الجوهريه بين الجنرال
البرهان وحميته في هذا الموقف
وكما اتذكر فان الخلاف يستند او يقوموا
على حقيقه ان الجيش
الجنرال البرهان يريد لقوات دعم السريع ان
تكون مدمجه في الجيش خلال فتره سنتين في
حين ان حماتي دعا الى ان تكون الفتره عشره
سنوات
هذا طبعا اختلاف كبير وفرق كبير وهو
اختلاف في ليس لا يمكن فيها ان تحصل
نتيجته اي دمج الدمج هذه القوات في الجيش
امر واقع اساسي وجوهري وضروري للوصول الى
حكم مدني في السودان وهذا هو الاتجاه الذي
عليه هي اتفاقيه الاطار وشعب السودان كلهم
حقيقه ان الجان او جان
الجانبين العسكري وشبه العسكري يتقاتلان
هذا ايضا هو نتيجه وهذا فعلا ما هو سبب
الانقلاب اللي حصل في اكتوبر 2021
حول ضروره
الاحتفاظ
بخطوتهم الصناعيه
الاقتصاديه سواء الصناعات العسكريه او
مناجم الذهب التي حميد وقوات الدعم السريه
يتمتعون بها اضافه الى انك خوف او خشيه من
قبل الجيش ومن قوات الدعم السريع بان
جرائمهما
افلاتهم العقاب سينتهي ولابد ان يكون هناك
نوع من محاسبه لهم وهذه الوقائع ولهذه
الحقائق هي هي حسب رايي هي التي
تدفع وتقف وراء
قيام الجيش
بالاختلافات مع
الاحتقاد نعم السريعه في الوضع الحالي هو
فعلا يعني الخلافات كبيره بين الجانبين
وليس من السهل الحديث عن حل سريع لها ولكن
سيدي الرشيد
الا يفرض الميدان نفسه هنا على كل الاطراف
يعني بعد سته ايام من المعارك حتى الان لم
يتغير اي شيء على مستوى السيطره والمعارك
ما زالت مستمره الا يمكن لهذا الامر ان
يكون ضاغطا على القوات المسلحه على الجيش
وعلى عبد الفتاح البرهان من اجل القبول
بمبدا التفاوض رغم انه سابقا كان قد
اعتبرها مجموعه متمرده وحلها قانونا وغير
ذلك لكن الان هو يعترف بها من جديد
ويدافع عنها
خطواته موجوده يستدعى بعض القوات من
الحاميات في الولايات السودان المختلفه
استضع بعضها
العسكريه موجوده خرطوم للدفاع عنها لكن كل
هذه القوات الان لا تقاتل ليس هناك معركه
مفتوحه هناك مناوشات وهذه المناوبات
السودان بلد مترامي الاطراف كثير
الان في السودان محصوره فقط في محافظه
الخرطوم وليس في ولايه الخرطوم صحيح قوات
الدعوه السريع عندها مجموعات
متناثره في المحافظات الاخرى محافظه
البحري وشرق النيل وتوجد ايضا في في اطراف
الخصوم لكن
لا توجد معارك مفتوحه في كل هناك السودان
الامنه
ما عدا محافظه الخرطوم ومحافظه الخرطوم
فيها قوات نخبه هي الاقرب للسيد غايب
التمرد حميتي هي التي تقبل
يعني تمارين في المئه يمكن ان تقول من
قوات الدعم السريع وقاده القوات الان هم
يعني اعلنوا ولا هم للجيش السوداني ولكن
البقيه القوات التي تقاتل في محافظه واحده
الجيش لا يخوض معها معركه مفتوحه الان
قديش يستخدم فقط
التغانه وبعض الطائرات المسيره الدرونز
واحيانا في احيان يستخدم الطائرات الحربيه
لكن
الجيش لا يدير معركه حقيقه يعني في مهاره
يعني ويشاهد السودانيون ولكن
القوات الدعم السري
ع ان تقود
حرب يعني ان تحرق الاحياء وتحرق المواقع
وتحريق وسط المدينه لكن الجيش
سيد حافظ اذا اخذنا بالاعتبار ما قاله
السيد رشيد المعتصم 80% من قوات الدعم
السريع وقادتها عدوا وانضموا الى الجيش
عمليا ميزان القوه على الارض يميل بقوه
ليس فقط في الخرطوم بل ايضا في باقي
الولايات لصالح قوات الجيش اذا اذا كان
الوضع الميداني كذلك لماذا سيكون البرهان
مضطرا فعلا
للتفاوض وسبق كما ذكرنا ان اعلن عن حل
قوات الدعم السريع ومن بقي منها يقاتل
باتا بنظر الجيش قوات متمرده ما الذي
يجبره على التفاوض اذا كان هو عمليا حتى
اللحظه كما يقول الرشيد منتصر
هذا يدل على ان الذي غير صحيح البراء نفسه
ليوم اعترف بان قوات الدعم التي تنتشر في
كل مكان يقال وانها تحتل او تسيطر على
مناطق الخدمات والمناطق الاستراتيجيه
والامراكز الشرطه وعلى المطار وذكر ذلك
ذكر انها منتشره وانه لا يريد يعني ضربها
لانه لا يريد يعني تحطيم تاثير تتاثر
البنيه التحتيه لكن بالفعل هو استخدم
الطائرات خلال الفتره الماضيه والحديث
الذي ذكره ضيفك ايضا غير دقيقه وذكر
محافظه الخرطوم لا شيء لا شيء اسمه محافظ
الخرطوم هنا هناك محليه الخرطوم هناك
محليه محليه يعني هناك يعني لا شيء اسمه
محافظه الخرطوم منتشره في هذه الاماكن
كلها التي ذكرتها محليات جبلاوليه
وفي شارع الختم وعدد من هذه الحقيقه لكن
هو احد لكن الذي يجعل الجميع يذهب للتفاوض
هناك نوع من توازن القوه
هناك ايضا حرب بمدن وشوارع لم تحسن لصالح
اي طرف من الاطراف ايضا الذي يجعل الجميع
يقبلون بالتفاوض هو يعني رغبتهم في عدم
اكبر الذي تم
نزيف الدم وايقاف
الذي يعني الاستنزاف الذي يعني يجري حاليا
للدوله وللمؤسسات وتعطير حياه المفروض
وكذلك قناعتهم بانهم لا يستطيعون حسم هذه
المعارف من قبل المؤسسه العسكريه خاطئه
لانها يمكن كثير من المجموعات حتى مجموعات
التي كانت تسميها بتمرض في دارفور تقول
بانها يمكن ان تحشمها في اسبوع او في شعر
استمرت الحرب اكثر من عقدين وبالتالي
الحرب ليس هو الوسيله التي يمكن تحقيقها
من خلالها الاهداف خاصه بعد ثوره الذي
يمكن ان يحقق الاهداف للجميع هو التفاوض
هو الحوار هو تقديم الحجه للجميع
في هذا المجال الاطراف اقليميه ودوليه
تواكب عن كثب التطورات في السودان وما
يصدر عن قاده الطرفي القتال من تصريحات
ومواقف في جديد المواقف البيت الابيض قال
ما نركز عليه الان هو حث طرفي الصراع في
السودان على وقف العنف والالتزام بوقت
اطلاق النار الخارجيه الامريكيه من جانبها
قالت نحث الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع على وقف اطلاق النار الى ما بعد
العيد
للحديث عن هذه المواقف اسال ضيفي من
بوستون تيموفي كرني يعني هي مجرد مناشده
لا اكثر ولا اقل يعني هل اسقط في يد
الولايات المتحده اليست لديها وسائل ضغط
حقيقيه على طرفي القتال من اجل وقف العنف
او على الاقل الالتزام بهدنه
لعده ايام
الشيء الهام حاليا هو يتحقق وقفه عفوا
مهدنه على الاقل لفتره العيد هذا هو
افضل نتيجه ممكنه حاليا اتوقعها وراها
حاليا هناك عده احتمالات اخرى وواحد منها
هي استمرار القتال ومن ثم التعامل مع
الفائز او المنتصر اذا فعلا كان اي من
جانبين بامكانه ان ينتصر نظرا لموضوع اي
اي جهه لديها قوه اكبر
وقاده كفوئين وتكتيكات عسكريه كفوءه وربما
بعد ذلك البدء بالتهديد بيفرض عقوبات على
المنتصر اذا لم يتحول الى حكم مدني في
السودان العقوبات طبعا ستنجح فقط اذا كانت
كل الدول المجاوره للسودان وايضا الكثير
من الدول الاجنبيه
وافقت على ان هذه الطريقه للعمل
الامكانيه الثانيه هي دراسه
مساله دور
دولي كبير
يمكن ان يقوم به مثلا الاتحاد الافريقي
وربما
القيام بتدخل بطريقه بوضع ضغوط اكبر على
الجانبين المتقاتلين في السودان
وامكانيه اخرى هي تكون هو استخدام مجلس
الامن في الامم المتحده ربما
لايثاره الفصل السابع اي فرض السلام قوات
حفظ السلام في وهذه سكون خطوه كبيره الى
الامام وهي خطوه انا اتردد جدا على دعمها
في مثل هذا الوضع الشيء الرئيسي والمفتاح
حسب رايي هو انعل القاده السودانيه من
العسكريين
وحميتي عليهما ان يقبلا مسؤوليتهما في
حمايه الشعب السوداني وليس
استمرار في وضعهم في وضع الخطر ولهذا
المناسبه عبر عن تعزيه الى اسر الاكثر من
300 الذي قتلوا كبير من العسكري انت قدمت
ثلاثه عفوا قدمت ثلاثه سيناريوهات مهمه
جدا
انتظار من الذي سيفوز
اعطاء الاتحاد الافريقي دور في الضغط على
الجانبين
وقرار من مجلس الامن يضع السودان تحت
البند السابع الولايات المتحده برايك اي
من هذه السيناريوهات تفضل في هذه المرحله
بالحكم على ما رايته
وسمعته من تصريحات وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه والبيت الابيض اعتقد ان
الولايات المتحده تعمل فقط
بالتعاون مع القوه الدول والقوى الاقليميه
مع دول الغربيه الاوروبيه الاخرى لاستمرار
في وضع ضغوط
لفظيه على المقاتلين للتوصل الى هدنه قد
تؤدي الى المفاوضات
شكرا جزيلا لكم في كارني ميم بوستن السفير
الامريكيه السابق في السودان وشكرا لضيفنا
من الخرطوم حافظ كبير الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي وكذلك نشكر ضيفنا من الخرطوم ايضا
الرشيد المعتصم الباحث في مركز الخرطوم
للحوار
هذا الموضوع سيبقى متفاعلا على الصعيد
الدولي والاقليمي نظرا للتطورات العسكريه
المتلاحقه الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي حلقتنا
من برنامج ما وراء القدر نشكر متابعتكم
والى اللقاء باذن الله